louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
[Music]
I
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I must dash we calling you oka hi - I am
NOT a tribal citizen 1000 then you ready
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
[Music]
which arose
[Music]
like
GD p-- there really is an important
distinction of
I am NOT a
[Music]
[Music]
okay welcome to the show
I am your president Donald J Trump the J
stands for Jay I am going to be filling
in for louder with for Steve accredited
a who's now great knows the bug Club
from what I understand it's the best the
very best club the very very I was ever
said that's what they tell me
by half cherubim lawyer bill Richman is
here today
let us Mel are you doing sir mr.
president thank you feeling very well
how are the tariffs going excellent
we're ready to get rid of them for you
thank you very much and what that
railroad on my desk by Monday done
quarter blank carriage so mr. president
voted for me by an increased margin
above 8% now yeah that's been you my
black president divided by 4 is 2
percent but I'll take it
ok don't get cute today gee Mort Gerald
a oh absolutely the day this one is
actually a tribute all the way around
we've got Camus cabernet sauvignon on
the top care it actually says 45 mr.
president okay the vintage of the bottle
is 2017 the year that you took office
okay it's a bigger bottle so it's huge
and if you look right here it actually
says I've seen 45 that was taken from
Pete but gig cellar we couldn't we have
Gavin McGinnis on the show today he's
about to go to prison
Oh we'll talk with him about that well
but before we provide both of the top
five crazy it's bo-buds from Democrats
we'll be talking about today but I do
want to ask for out of all the demon
Kratz see what out there who's asked
would you most like to see me kick in
the 2020 election frankly I have my
favorite I think we but we'd like to
hear from you yeah okay
I know people expected me to address the
hearings but
okay irrelevant nothing new has happened
Herodias half China but that's a legal
term yes circles between baseball and
boxing yeah at Wharton it's amazing yeah
I was going to be a lawyer but the bone
spurs prevented me from using the bar no
I can see how that would happen sir
so let's get you what is affecting
American real Americans net The Lying
fake does okay with the impeachment
we'll know more about can we just have a
few left let's start with this new poll
that says politics are driving deben
Kratz insane from Axios this comes from
excite us
70% of demon Kratts are haters frankly
and losers who are angry about it that's
a direct quote I would never say they
say it's what they say yeah of course
angry about America leaving them feeling
like quote and I quote I do quote folks
strangers in their own land could you
believe that Democrats are angry with
the greatest economy ever they'd rather
a powerful Isis that a powerful America
oh my gosh this country I have to tell
you is doing so much wedding lowest
unemployment highest labor force
participation rate we have won $5,000 an
increase for the median household income
it'll close yeah you know much it was
under Obama know what was negative to
know it was what doesn't but it could
have been negative I wouldn't want it
we're doing shut you put by anything
let's try the way I bought a Gerald seed
uh no water please the reason Gerald see
next day shipping
rocky bad show Jeff Bezos
is gonna get it I think this year
reasonable the country is doing so much
winning folks that they should be
singing about it frankly okay from the
rooftops ed listen when it comes to
singing I'm tops get ready for now
that's what I call Trump in this
compilation your favorite president
makes these hits his own don't go
chasing GDP the median income is a
better metric and who can forget the
beat but King song splish Splash they
were taking a bath and it was a couple
of eggs voted on by the attendees at the
weekly White House talent show this
collection is sure to make you want to
get up and dance Nicki don't lose my
number
might replace pitch with someone else
support the police because they weren't
really really hard news it's all fake
those b.i.g see that's how you spell
hillary b IG c synonym for hello Rick
welcome to the hook Ocala Ford yeah
there's a homeless face poop all over
the place lots of poop now that's what I
call shrub nothing like a truck they
won't see me cuz that call one eight
hundred twenty four details you could
order with only four easy payments of
for Chilean 9500 steel you can allocate
the funds as I see fit
yeah well by the way do you know how
many Grammys that album was nominated
for all of them so they're telling me
now that the president former president
I should say forum Jimmy Carter was
hospitalized for a procedure to reduce
pressure on his brain believed to be
caused by years of big idiot oh wow does
it peanut farmer take it to you and
actually I heard he's okay are you sure
yeah yeah he's totally fine could that
be verified
yeah yeah very sure okay here's the next
story I like this right here I think the
scroll is
that way we go there hard you do because
my fingers are so large in masculine
they are yes yes it just gives me a
notice on my screen and says too much
testosterone Wow incredible from this
side of the room I said Mira Mira
and the world and before I can finish
the says please stop you're intimidating
me every gentle creature its rug to hate
yeah it is rug tear here on the next
story
there was Pocahontas this week yeah you
know who poked Abe
three black POCs she put in her cabinet
please run her she didn't answer the
question folks nope not at all getting
that sale any black POC sparks that
called the pots yeah I got time to say P
I took I have a busy man I don't have
time to be pronouncing acronyms so words
to my mirror it's a busy day but what
she couldn't name what watch this folks
Kanye West okay boom my my HUD secretary
dr. Ben Hobart then there's diamond and
or silk over there are named for black
box I know so many black box the best
black pot I know the best black bass
okay and let me give you some more okay
Candice Owens that's a Park Tiger Woods
that's another part the hodgetwins to
Park dos box oh I see
[Laughter]
be gems don't I know that all too well
sir this past Sunday was the annual
People's Choice Awards okay
and of course the people's favorite
president wasn't invited so I don't know
it'd be called swamp the choice that's
right my thoughts because I know you
want to buy the people here in this
week's hardly would admit it but that's
catchy it is it's long it's a little
long but so the first we have is this
happy couple in Hollywood look my old
tissue but it turns out Gwen Stefani's
in their makeup
next is singer pink okay looks like if
Boy George hadn't gotten a maybe he did
get aged and reinvented himself as pig
goes that's a conspiracy theory life
like my daughter she constantly
reinvents herself you have like a virgin
and that beautiful stranger and then she
rapes Drake oh oh that's a poor choice
Drake seemed to like it
didn't oppose it that much he did not he
did not resist okay next just where I
star
Kurama Brown you know this one quarter
black dirt oh yeah I had a joke for this
one but it was all flourish oh you can't
do that you're better than that no
moving on I guess a youtuber who are in
my crosshairs yes channa mung mung do
you know this one could have money I
don't know I
I like the color slack-jawed less hard
slightly with Jessica Rabbit Oh Jessica
Rabbit by the way really did it for me
to do for you just what a kid because
dr. ben Carson is a doctor yes if he
could make a Jessica Rabbit yeah and
yeah we separated conjoined twins but
apparently the science is not quite at
some weird science level oh come on yeah
to put max dollars under the second term
sir we'll see finally there is a fashion
designer Jeremy Scott folks Jeremy Scott
just made it look like he's got a
handmade menstrual cycle
this week's corner black was a little
trigger-happy yeah my people first time
that he's been a quarter early oh wow
this is the first time yes often he's
reading and quarter black time yes it's
a fact Beach's late thank you for the
exposure he tips like a Canadian okay
I'm gonna stand that folks Wow okay okay
listen listen listen
yes sir listening excuse me this is
exciting folks okay this year's list of
Oprah's Favorite Things has arrived
oh good notably absent from Oprah's
Favorite Things list Steadman's may not
make the list doing great
folks it Trump's America even disgusting
fat black lesbian parks holding their
own can't release a list of things that
their maid uses to tell you to buy them
oh I'm sure that Oprah Winfrey is using
the nespresso right yeah no not at all
there's a little Honduran lady who
shields her eyes because she can't look
at the face directly and says I think
Nespresso should be on the list by the
it's hard to do what I've heard it's
more the fishhook really yeah like New
York right in my truck into the ether
5.0 yes yes man who will be well that's
not difficult to know
it's not your fault that his father was
only there three-quarters of the time
that's true that's true
it could be worse that's where we're
going to I'm going to start more YMCAs
for your shawl that's all right yeah yes
I love basketball because I know you
prefer nerdy stuff Yeah right but we
will have a room for Magic the Gathering
Place and no one can tell you of either
race that you don't belong in a coheed
and cambria on repeat sweet I don't
speak Amazon Washington Post okay there
they're releasing a mother report
graphic novel series right down my alley
they say the book provides a unique
graphic depiction okay which is quite
frankly the greatest hoax in American
history correct now you know man
Watergate yeah yeah yeah do you know the
with Chucky was named after that hoax
because it's child play I didn't see
where you were going oh so the dog was a
ginger which is a recessive gene and
it'll be gone what did you expect son
yeah yeah then you remade it and
connected their little demon child with
a smart home it was a bad idea
Tara very bad comic book shuts folks
okay if you want to read a real frankly
comic book the best comic book I wrote a
comic book it's the greatest comic book
it's called Trump loves Hillary kills
here's that I loved it when you left
before the punch line
[Laughter]
you couldn't get Gerald to see here but
it's a great name sir shipping don't say
okay excuse me next day shipping when
its two-day shipping it's because now I
have to deal with cutesy McKay over here
I followed that sir yeah Burke excuse me
it's called Trump loves Hillary kills
here's a mug Club exclusive
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh hurry up everyone the quicker we get
you undocumented Democrats to
Pennsylvania the quicker you could vote
in 2020 mr. president you clearly made
America great again your approval rating
is an astonishing 117 percent I love
America but mr. president
crooked ages at the wall whatever will
we do
don't worry I'll handle this one no it's
super trap Oh [ __ ] I was a Golden
Gloves in high school see super Trump
here are mucho spacious for your
wardrobe
I'm sorry oh okay we yeah we can do the
bulb description it was a fantastic huh
and I was laughs the name is hilarious
although it's true and very descriptive
it's just a funny name for a cure sunken
space of co-hosts ah you don't mean that
sir could you please change the winner
of the trivia contest winner is Dustin
Jenson Jepsen Jepsen Jepsen's okay what
old nerd who actually corrected us on
our question about guru Crowder
correcting us by the way if you add more
content like this do join the mug Club
Yoga is the best club from what I
understand I haven't watched it sits
Glenn Beck did she do face but yeah we
have made amends has been on this show
so has my son there you go after he
hunted an elephant there you go all
right yeah so good honey millions the
problem with an elephant is you have to
take it out with one shot because it
never forgets never who that every rush
like never I will never forget you Komi
okay no boom
president never forgets did you know
that half Chinamen have Chinamen yeah
excuse me I have a item in excuse me
excuse me
he went to Guantanamo Bay yes
yeah yeah yeah it was a lot of funny
with a Weger a week a week and we spent
so much in the wiggers look you can
google it actually Bing it Oh even if
you have to ask that bentback paper clip
right we should have a Trump search
control or the posi gorillas trumpet the
purple gorilla because they would never
have a black gorilla there would be
nobody will tell you the weiners are in
Guantanamo Bay Chinese Muslims who we we
support we love ya we spend four times
the amount on keeping them alive in
Guantanamo Bay then our own violent
felons here in America first let's let's
take care of Tookie Williams first first
yes got to take care of Tookie if a
Weger has a four-course meal and Tookie
Williams is in the dirt DMX is rolling
over in his grave that's true he's alive
isn't it I don't think so Jimmy Carter
is he's still alive yes he is totally
that could change it a New York minute
no yeah he is very old good song a New
York minute show great song is that on
the album as well done Henley as a
national hero yeah yeah you have to
separate frankly the art from the artist
yes yes of course that's the only way I
stab myself from strangling chaud ped if
only you hadn't restrain Jersey and on
the flip side that's how I take a
picture smiling with Kid Rock when if I
hear that copy of Sweet Home Alabama
talking about Northern Michigan one more
time I'm gonna beat his wife sir
northern Michigan's the treasure okay so
these are the tap have you been watching
yeah it losers okay who think they think
they're gonna beat me so it yeah no way
no who
you think has the greatest chance of
being the most successful runner-up to
me but I thought we would go through the
tap greatest greatest hits like Don
Cherry by the way yes it's a tragedy
what's going on but the most
cringe-worthy hits from the Democratic
candidates and we'll have Gavin
McGuinness on after this um so let's
just go through this to see how horrible
horrible people let's see how horrible
they really honorable number what let's
go through Bernie Sanders his most
cringe-worthy moment last campaign it
would have been when he had his mic
stolen by the black that was pretty bad
if that's not allegorical for what would
happen in an anti-christian to kitsch
Society I would I want a turkey okay
the blacks gonna take your stuff you you
old Jew no no you don't stand a Jew both
chance in hell my family no you're fine
you're not by blood but by sex yeah yeah
that works so here is Bernie shaky
traction most cringe-worthy moment here
we go look he tried to hit a punching
bag okay he keeps going for more he
keeps going for more look that old Jew
has heart
okay does look at it does probably not
belongs a fighter
distasteful yeah I respect it and he
never you never got him down Everlast
speed bag from Dick's that's perfect I'm
just getting my member for Pete but cake
okay here he is right now okay
hanging out this is for me the most
cringe but I guess I would never say
this is what people tell me okay these
were submitted by you you can by the way
tweet at the s Crowder because that's
the Twitter right now right no my
Twitter
he needs some followers folks yeah do
you see the costumes it mr. Crowder put
sad he can dress up like a broad weekend
it right right yeah yeah but he'll be
thrilled with this next one hanging out
okay excuse me with a couple of parks
don't let the kids see I talk to you
it's all your new moons fly all right
mayor people to the blacks as a gay man
than committing misdemeanors let's but
it's cool don't they actually just gave
him high C because he's dead what year
old they did not they that showed the
graduation song is high C correct yeah
as we go dad
we remember right oh the chatter man I
had on retainer there yeah okay
different song for you tries to appeal
to the the black parks okay yeah it is
shameful it's horrible
let me show you how it's done
45 it works every time
Billy Dee Williams Williams the only
member of the Old Republic they chose to
dress like a pimp
gold tassel man hey mr. Lucas I should
wear how about a cape
oh great and can I fight Bubba Fett with
a Cadillac with rolling ribs yes yes
spinners that's how you would do it I
love it oh okay what's with the have you
seen what's with the anger issues okay
so much anger so much hate please stick
things in his mouth could you see you're
uncomfortable let's move on it's funny
though it really funny it's wrong not
only to hate but to have a phobia of the
quiz okay sure I'm not a phobia folks
next one I think is number two I don't
know in the election they'll all be
number two excuse me number three okay
we'll fix that in post along with the
Bulge yes I got just mustard Kamala
Harris I wish she she didn't drop out no
yes as of now I don't know I've seen
gang rapes more gentle than what Tulsi
Gabbard did to her mm-hmm aw come on a
little abridge worthy moment where she
claims that she smoked weed okay excuse
me smoked weed in college and listen to
Tupac okay at the hodgetwins to park
yeah and Snoop Dogg well doing so at the
same time here
have you no smokes okay I didn't I did
she's so cool smokes weed oh my goodness
oh yeah definitely
to pasture okay she graduated college
frankly okay tricks
she's that big truthful in eighty seven
over three years before snoop or Park
had any albums won so either she has a
DeLorean
oh she was smoking well locking up
nonviolent drug offenders in massive
numbers who by the way I've read have
done more than Sanders and the blacks
right you're not one in the same minds
you yeah
not more for both than any president
okay look they're just can't give credit
no they should the credit is due
yes we will give you crazy on Sarah do
well thank the pleasure is all yours
yes by the way notification bell okay
frankly if you're subscribed because we
don't know if subscriptions work ad just
there's a new video I guess the Crowder
does he does every day yeah what time I
believe it's 8 o'clock Eastern 8 o'clock
Eastern because one another next day
shipping Fiasco though he worked out in
my favor I'm with you half of these
videos okay
he dresses up like abroad really I mean
it's just so he's got that going for him
it is it really 50 percent which is e 6
which is said Wow ok next up my favorite
my favorite photos really is this your
favorite this [ __ ] yes absolutely
[ __ ] likes this one yeah of course
you love the Native Americans are Asian
well the correct term is Aboriginal oh
there I was gonna go with American
Asians because they came across the
Bering Strait and so that's where the
land bridge come across the Bering
Strait paid but gig
across the barre gay it's just a game
any spins on him like a dreidel oh wow
excuse me if you want that for your
president that's your that's your that
would not be my choice that's your
choice to make
okay no the country will not choose the
country will not choose yeah no Jews
will not choose did you see what I did
with shoes yeah rhymes a little excuse
me I've been hanging out with Kanye okay
Wow he does have an impact on you rhymes
all right the Jews will choose Jimmy
Choos Donald Trump just need a beat okay
so Elizabeth Warren
Pocahontas she tried to mate very
musically I hope they tell me tell me I
couldn't do American Idol because it's
like the Olympics where pros can not
enter your welcome Kelly Pickler yeah so
would have been second Pocahontas tried
to take a chapter out of Al she's booked
by live-streaming herself and she was
she's ready for press she really wants
you to know okay that she drinks she
drinks beer she's just like yeah hold on
a sec I'm gonna get me a beer
hop beer she's the other one smokes weed
she drinks a presidential campaign or a
bad installment of AAA what step are you
on number four being a [ __ ] he likes it
I like I don't care thank you okay yep
question two the beer drinkers out there
okay how many of you
drink a beer like this look look at this
clip she goes to drink a beer oh she
must have gotten lessons on how to drink
beer from Pete but cake both of them did
a tap-dance on Barry gay
oh no going hard enough should we call a
callback I like to just like the economy
by the way she also there's so much with
Elizabeth Warren in case you don't know
this is do it I don't want to stack the
deck but please run this broad okay yeah
please if I'm in the red corner I want
to look to the blue corner and she the
one 1000 64th Cherokee yeah an adage yes
yeah the native Asian sensation there
would be nothing but a trail of tears
because this [ __ ] needs a Wounded Knee
Wow I like that many references in you
guys I just can't keep up it's fantastic
yes figure-skating for you hey here's
another one okay she says that she
prefers netflix and chill' to Broadway
dinner I asked her what you might cringe
go okay Netflix and chill or Broadway
and dinner
Oh Netflix and chill okay say it ain't
so
oh my gosh I wonder if she even knows
what that means you know fairly sure I
don't think so but she may know what it
means
police know as a hooker
no no no it's a tribe it's posterity
Apaches the Cherokees the Algonquin the
Iroquois and the hookers the hooker -
yeah she was chief such a good chief
with powwow town okay and this is
another one I don't quite fully
understand okay
but I think audio Wade will explain
after more Pocahontas the hits keep
coming her love for some big structure
named Bailey yeah what are they would it
what are they cheering them it's a big
structural Bailey I think yeah I think
it's the building next door to fall on
her some stockings with their feet
rolling yes yeah yeah that's what we
call foreshadowing Wicked Witch of the
reservation yes what chatter but as
jokes she does thank you he has jokes
they can totally head over because I
don't have that hat you don't speaking
of yin and yang we go Andrew full
cherubim yang full now I will say that
full Andrew yet full [ __ ] he seems
pretty decent is first cherubic cook
okay as House Democrats go nice guy but
it is pretty rough this video of him
crowd surfing at a campaign event
okay have to see this for yourself
wait wait wait let's go back and look at
yang he likes ya he's getting the inside
information on his competition yeah only
candidate who can do the crowd surfing
because he's 4 foot nothing how we apply
the goods over I do want to go across
the rib we'll go to chilled a because
I'm contractually obligated yes yes who
do you think would be the easiest to
beat well of course we don't beat all of
them but we think would be hardest and
easier you're gonna beat them by a mile
I think you unfortunate two months and
for two miles sir you're right the
easiest to beat I think would be pitch
for 2.4 kilometers what it's interesting
to you I have international holdings as
well it's confusing sometimes the
conversion so thank you for doing it
that so conversions just hoping that if
I could doesn't convert to Jew it's true
that the things too late is real I would
say you would beat him by 10 miles
it was hero Biden ok I think he's the
toughest competition you think he's the
toughest and Pete but gig is the easiest
Kamala Harris won't make it much longer
so I'm not even including her feet but
gig is easy ok yeah I think that
Elizabeth Warren will probably be the
easiest for you to beat sir I think yeah
Pete you know I think so and then I also
think I think Bernie Sanders would
probably be a little tougher forgive me
for saying so yeah no listen
yes hard ok for now yeah poor weak
valves
he's been improved quarterblack I know
it's gonna be Booker no no I guess I'm
gonna say Joe Biden's gonna be a hardest
and Elizabeth Warren the easiest okay
okay okay we're getting what we call
could said shish mmm I'm skilled I think
I'm still right though sir yeah yeah you
would no way next day shipping bishop
are still waiting I think that you would
beat chief lip-lock beer first be the
easiest for you thank you I think I
think the hardest for you to blame it
would be my cousin he looks exactly like
both of them Andrew yang you people
copulate like rabbits we do we can
taking over yes I would have said retch
but you people eat them as a gift for
the people I'll give you the secret code
for our restaurants so no dog meat when
I go to the Chinese restaurant I just
ordered the splinter I got their
reference going back and watching Ninja
Turtles no no no not the first one this
secret
excuse me no it's best to leave it there
yes yes no no no we're more homeward
bound than Tianjin teenage me folks
great because I like it what animals
took like p.m. it's always always but I
always confused the homered bad babe
with the Jurassic Park theme really I'm
so similar I think it's easy to not did
you ask your dad
travelin hurts yeah and it says she
doesn't know what if the old disgusting
bird watcher gives her full cream milk
cancer lactose-intolerant
oh that's just mean that's abuse we're
still alive I would lock him up yeah
well you should write and give the code
to Hillary so that he would hang himself
with paper bedsheets
we do have to go to Gavin McInnes but I
will say this of all of these people
folks listen look for this right now in
this in this election we have the best
Academy that we've had in modern
American history like a lowest
unemployment we have highest labor force
participation rate we have a job surplus
okay that micro himself couldn't fill
more black businesses being started
Louis black unemployment rate okay crime
is at an all-time low
$5,000 median household income increase
it used to be about the economy stupid
but now you will see whichever candidate
this is talk about anything but the
Academy grad known that talk about the
Academy because I'm stupid and we will
put that on a bumper sticker for then
there's a board and please dear God you
hover okay yes you are make it
Pocahontas Warren please please don't
tell her that but do it because I will
use reverse say No
gonna get in McKinney will be back this
market country where
black rifle cook buffet okay
Oh faith thing okay folks frankly it's
the best coffee out there
ar-15 coffee m16 coffee it's a coffee
with bazooka Bazooka Joe the coffee look
at the BRIT can we get the hero shot
today still make Bazooka Joe he used to
be a petty rifle of color coffee
this coffee should be dating a
Kardashian like this coffee is the best
coffee black rifle coffee and unlike
other companies who claim small batch of
premium black rifle coffee is it roasted
frankly until you place your order
making sure it's the freshest coffee
many people don't know it's a it's a
bead it goes bad coffee go to black
rifle coffee dot-com / Crowder enter the
promo code Crowder to receive 20% off
your first order of black rifle coffee
okay great
simple give me a diet coke that today
you're not setting your best everybody
said you write back look it over that
well let's keep building this wall there
you go brick by brick my wall frankly
shoots fire you see and you're gonna pay
for it it's dry
hey guys in the chat let me know what
you'd like me to put in my boat I think
again alligators it spikes check out our
second channel youtube.com slash Crowder
bits if you think I'm gonna be closing
pedophile Island here in the fourth of
July weekend this place will be crawling
with toddler tourists you've got another
thing coming with an iPhone
Doug Spence I know everyone's thinking
while Stephen got really ugly and fat a
nation a nation yeah I'm very a finding
very low mania this chick makes me I
invested guitar solo
actually almost ran over someone with my
car by accident who was there was a
whole lineup of people to go see you
guys and then one of them this was a
time where pokemons to go was big and he
was walking out in the middle of street
I think oh my god I did a manga hat on I
think that's the last thing I need but
he was so nice but he's like I'm sorry
man and he made named some Pokemon oh
you - squirtle or something else it was
right right outside of the bottles to
lock your wing - died
[Music]
you
[Music]
okay do we ever we have our guests to do
at the show he's ready he's on the
program he's ready okay our next guest I
hear
frankly is a fan of buyed I haven't
spoken with them and it makes me very
sad because he's going to prison so our
next guest you can find him at free
speech TV Gavin McGinnis you're there
sir have you been preparing for your
time in the Keeney I this is the first
I'm hearing in prison I have friends who
are on trial and I have two I have three
friends in jail but I wasn't aware of a
charge that I'm going through okay so to
be clear you're not going into labor
not to my knowledge but I'm glad you
brought that up because I have max Haran
John kinsman have been locked up for a
silly brawl with an Tifa there for years
I was hoping you would pardon them and
then we have another guy David curico
see he's facing a trial now and we got
this kid Geoff Young in Rikers
Tommy trigger and then of course Roger
stone but it sounds to be like you say
you're not going to prison and you keep
naming people who are in prison or
prison bound yeah okay but you were not
a bug step correct and would it make
sure I have this right not presently but
it wouldn't surprise me I'm the next
that's well good that makes me very
happy to hear because they've heard very
good things about you gathered across
the board and I also hear that you're
quite you're quite fond of Trump I was
one of the earliest guys you know Ted
Cruz came out I thought he was okay and
then I realized as they beat him up that
we need a lion in there we need someone
who can handle this maniacal left is
what they say is that the judge will pay
for the sins of the father and I think
that the grassy knoll killing JFK
chickens are coming home to roost for
Cruz and they said he thought this that
would put that's what they tell me
that's not his fault but his father
right yeah I shouldn't have brought up
Cruz I apologize
but you know when you said when having
imposed said they're only covering you
in the entertainment section and you
said didn't your husband leave you for a
man I think he made the right choice
and I just went this is my guy thank you
by the way Heidi Cruz
there's nothing wrong with her when I
was saying Heidi Cruz you look at that
face
it's a good it's a good face it's a good
face right I regret bringing up Ted Cruz
I don't know why I think it's a great
day to face so what is going on with the
boys who are very proud you have some of
them going to prison you are that and
one of them is Indian yeah so the two
that are in prison now we're getting an
appeal for them it's just insane that
you do for years for a 17-second
irrelevant fight no victims and then
this third guy the crazy thing is there
was three guys right two white one brown
they separated the brown guys trial
because it didn't help the the hate
group narrative and they also John
kinsman's wife is black and they made
sure they never photographed her in the
courtroom and when he walked arm-in-arm
the cameras would just point down so
they had this predetermined narrative
ready in advance and that doesn't really
shock me what shocked me is that it
works you come up with you use an Tifa
as your source and the next thing you
know you win and men are in prison
that's why I'm so happy I don't I don't
want to interrupt but I but I'm going to
because I have to be accurate here in my
reporting I take it I take we know we
take it seriously folks the brown mad he
separated his trial from what I just
said that several deficit but that's
what you're telling me I've taken it as
fact I believe what you're telling me
now this Brown bed is not Mexican no he
is East Indian we would call them ok
sometimes East it and by the way I love
Easter dudes I have a great relationship
also any dudes from the West South some
of them are not brown they're darker
than the blacks they're darker than the
the parks I believe they're called the
untouchables over there yeah
also a shortcut area that filled no soap
he was a beat cop we don't do what
happened to beat cops Gavin you're Irish
that was a big thing they'd swig their
batad makes your kids word out of school
I think we should break back beat cops
like you know the cops who got in that
altercation with Eric Holder where he
ended up dead if there was a beat cop in
that situation they would have known him
and they'd be like Eric what are we
doing here come on you were I don't want
to do exactly
and then he would swing his stick and
take a dip of bourbon let me ask you why
did they separate the trial okay with
the Beretta Indian because they want to
push these this gang this gang Jesus
they want to push this club as a hate
group so they said well if there's a
brown guy we have two white guys and a
brown guy we can't go race race race
city race race race Nazi Nazi Nazi but
if we just have the two white guys on
the stand then we can push that
narrative as long as we get the guy's
wife out of it and so it worked they're
serving four years and now that David's
trial is in like a couple weeks and I
don't know how they're gonna push that
trial call him crazy or something and
say that he he he hates himself they
they've done that in the previous trial
I wouldn't be surprised they could do
what they call temporary insanity which
is a fleeting crazy okay
I had a lady one of the apartments she
was in the basement apartment with lots
of cats she was crazy but now she stood
very well for herself and she works as a
secretary and she's not anymore
no no mr. president I hope you don't
feel like I'm trivializing this
interview I'm obviously very excited to
meet you I'm sorry to be focusing on
this and trying to get favors right out
of the gate asking for pardons I'm for
justice and it's just it's at the front
of my priority list if this was any
other time I would be talking about your
policy how ludicrous this impeachment is
I mean you asked you you asked for an
investigation into what is clearly a
crime that's your job and just beyond
that what's the matter with quid pro quo
I'm not gonna give you money if you're
some Mugabe dictator I don't understand
the charges I'm not familiar
even with the term the terminology quid
pro quo I don't know what you're talking
about there but I do I just I will look
at my list of Pardons after cadre and
see if we have time for I understood Hey
oh that's dad cherry he's from your
country that's right good AD by the way
great allies that could a big fan of the
Canadiens like what is your opinion your
thoughts I died cherry they talked about
at this channel yesterday and the fact
that he has been fired is horrible
horrible political correctness is a war
on noticing patterns if you are not
blind and you have ear holes you know
that there are certain pockets in Canada
where no one wears poppies and those
tend to be immigrant guys look at this I
fed this hat TC was under the desk
extra extra read re hey read all about
it I don't normally wear you don't you
think you see that mr. macginnis dad
that's true yeah it's like a peaky
blinders thing it doesn't really fit
your head it's a I just think that's
right okay dad sherry you were say so he
just said look if you're gonna come here
you should respect the poppy the poppy
is about all the Canadian soldiers who
died in World War one it's not like
we're asking a Vietnamese guy to support
the Vietnam War or something like that
it's just an homage to the the soldiers
and sailors and airmen to who fought for
us across the sea and it's disrespectful
not to to at least Revere that that's
all he said but because he used the
terminology you people and he happened
to be discussing immigrants the whole
country melted down and he's done and
because he refuses to apologize we'll
never see him again
it was something like 38 years every
Saturday Hockey Night in Canada my
entire life
as far as I could go before even before
I immigrated to Canada from Britain it
was Don Cherry Hockey Night in Canada
and now nothing because of the words you
people that's right I liked a little
diddly that you had there by the way
have you heard the Ballad of the Green
Berets are you familiar with that word
Oh glory glory what a heavenly
is that it no that's the sugar wigs hear
audio wait can we give me a beat it's
silver wigs I don't know the song apart
their chests
these are bad America's best the best do
you know that what it's good what I'm
not familiar with that it and I don't
want to sound disrespectful or
irreverent but I question that
paratroopers one where glory glory what
a heavenly way to die and the guys all
wrapped up in the cords and stuff and
he's a bloody mess and it's it shows
that soldiers understanding what's
really going on it's kind of you to the
top you go in and you punch it if a do
you feel sometimes frankly like a green
beret because symptoms that's that's how
I see you okay symptoms I see you as a
moderate Green Beret yeah I would never
yes never nor would anyone that I hang
out with just randomly attack Antipa for
no reason
Mark Bray had a book called the
anarchist handbook he did a whole book
tour across the country no one bothered
him no Patriot prayer showed up no
nothing but whenever we have a thing
they have to come to our stuff so yes in
self-defense I have fought these guys I
have your dad your dad
Fator yeah I said look at so many hats
down here I don't know where we're good
all these hats do you have you do a lot
of funny shows Kevin do you wear Betty
hats
yeah I I did a joke today on the show
about a ridiculous City ridiculousness
that show with rob drydek the skater so
I dressed up like a skater with the
sweatshirt and a funny rap II baseball
hat I think costumes really help the the
the momentum of the show and it looks
good on the thumbnails to have a lot of
different outfits yeah true yeah and you
were a skater correct
no I I mean I did skateboard around my
it's one of those things I could just
never get I could never really ollie
correctly you have some little short
guys then we're just going up the
halfpipe and catching air and I it was
like being I'm trying to become gay I
just couldn't quite get it well okay
listen let's not get it
because that's not something you try
that's something you are and we've had
so many gays vote frankly I love the
gays are very comfortable as wicked ways
Miley innopolis Peter Boykin million
wonderful games that's right Peter did
Boyk Michael Annapolis I think you're
getting the names a little but yeah I
think you are getting the dabes a little
but I just so Gavin what do you think
will be the the falling out where is it
going to lead with Todd sherry for
people who are familiar national hero at
Canada and Patriot what do you think
well do you think that this will US you
will there be just justice no he's done
forever that's the way it works with the
politically correct laughs if you don't
capitulate you're finished they're happy
to dead you they don't watch hockey
anyway good get rid of him and this guy
wasn't just a hockey commentator he was
an icon there's no one to compare him to
in America he had housing estates he had
clothing lines yet charities I mean he
was he was he was like you sir he wasn't
just one man he would he was a million
grant that is hide race high price for
dodge Harry
I said similar to you it was in it was a
tiny tiny little Canadian version of
what some of what you are that's right
well it's it's very flattering both to
dodge Jerry and to but mostly to Dodd
cherry okay I'm sure he's thrilled about
it let me go back to the Indian with the
the anti feh have you been followed the
story of the man who was hit by a tip
with a baseball bat
and now he could only speak through
Morse blink no I'm not familiar with
that case is that a brand new there was
a man who was hit by an T for struck of
the head and I believe the gentleman got
four years or six years
seriously yes that guy notice the media
never really mentioned his injuries they
just say there was a fight and this guy
got six years no the thing that happened
to our guys was a brawl that was just a
boo boo pop kick kick do do yes the
thing that happened
- that the ante fit with the I think it
was actually a steel baton that was
attempted murder they split his head
open
horrible yeah it's absolutely horrible
and now he has to speak with Blake I
don't know if you could see but I did
Bush quite a bit this right here get
government get are you do you know what
this is let's say let's wave our ship oh
right yeah SOS I got it right yes
also a great shot by stake okay we have
to go there's going to be an extended
internet version here for those who are
members of Mudd Club that is his program
at free speech TV to protect Gavin
McInnes oh we don't want him speaking
through blink code right folks that's
right we don't oh hey I'm just here to
tell you frankly that if you have a joy
bug Club yet I don't know what you're
waiting for
okay it's the best it's the best club
all right and I have that stuff I have
to get that's what they that's what they
say everyone says it's the best club
that's what they tell me not only do you
can access ok frankly to the whole Daily
Show which on YouTube what you get is
not daily ok but you also get access to
the whole blaze catalog and if that's
that enough reason for you it's the
perfect gift to piss Trudy off ok joy
Buckland
victus
[Music]
what's your home defense plan when it
comes to safety there's no substitute
for a quality firearm and if you're a
gun owner there's no replacement for
firearms legal protection firearms legal
protection provides lawful gun owners an
uncapped legal defense program 24/7
emergency hotline access to a network of
over 2,500 experienced attorneys legal
education on firearm laws in your state
via our mobile app and plans to protect
you every step of the way if you are
involved in a self-defense visit
firearms legal comm /lw see today
[Music]
okay okay
there's a web extent for folks who are
not yet on bug Club so much work cut it
at the clip so much more what was that
that you were doing that was a drowning
black man oh okay a big shed yeah yeah
no because I tell you what if you look
at the world land speed records they're
almost always set by the blacks very
good very good at running very fast not
the water but they still with water wigs
yeah okay so and that seems a little
long Petrelli dance I'll just put that
in the suggested bucks okay but that is
dead you feel like that okay usually I
understand that Crowder would take this
time to do when he cuz Crowder closes
okay frankly I'm not going to do that
because I don't need to inspire you what
I am going to do is show you how many
real-life people I've inspired right
here in the studio okay let's go let's
go take a look Colette follow me okay
all right let's go
you could cut coated black you could
come out quarter black and audio wait
for those who don't know all these
people
okay are employed by louder with Crowder
and hey everybody say hello okay let's
go let's go we'll go through here and
talk to everyone to see how President
Trump has inspired them okay
and you okay right here this gentleman
your name sir it's given ya bed okay
now given you look how have I inspired
you okay so I think you wouldn't even
spared me with okay
you look like you might have some little
ethnicity in your little ethnicity am i
right
your answer okay what and what is it it
is a little bit of Japanese okay they're
not [ __ ] their best and their
brightest folks okay let's go here and
by the way you've seen him climbing
poles okay before on this program he
loves getting on the pole and as I
understand it's branded Brendan's
birthday today ray okay and how old are
you today bread did I am
and how old is that in [ __ ] years okay
and how have I inspired you Brendon
you're really successful your go getter
that's true I can't argue let's keep
good okay I don't need a trip at the mic
cord because Ana Steven it's not exactly
Trump Tower so he doesn't have the
budget for a wireless mic look here look
his Colombian okay don't ask him with a
donkey in coffees but he's wearing that
because there's nothing like an
immigrant on a visa pandering folks how
has I inspired you okay
smooth Matty winners aren't losers I
don't know what that means but I know
that I would be in the former category
you're a winner by the way how did you
get here legally I don't believe it okay
let's continue we have this chair I
don't know he has a chair but he stands
up okay probably because he wants to be
ready to run in case ice shows up all
right - cute Matty who was in the studio
earlier okay
- cute Matty what are you doing right
now well maybe soon you can edit
yourself a boyfriend all right let's go
on to right here this is Tim from H
loves he tells everyone how they can't
have fun SAPT
or grab C's Tim how have I inspired you
you're you're very tall that's true and
unfortunately for him he can't change
that about himself okay
he took it's wrong to hate especially I
think they can't change it's okay you
have other good qualities what's your
best quality so quarterblack Garrett
you're right here and see for some
reason he sits in a wheelchair you could
see we have other chairs but he chooses
a wheelchair because he collects a check
both from ladder with Crowder and the
government how they inspired you you're
the best black president we have yep
that's right yeah yeah you're great
okay and what do you doing here what's
this can we show right here what he has
that is look okay
that is a Nintendo logo and who's this
Mexican he's a he's a laughing Mexican
he's laughing Mexican okay I wonder how
I wonder how old he is as well in
Brenden years okay and we have finally
audio eight is he's - there's nothing
interesting about audio ed so I want to
thank you for letting me host this show
today okay be sure to to join the club
it's it's a good club right folks it's
the best club that there is and I want
you to know that I appreciate it
okay I appreciate you helping me make
America great again and through it all I
stand tall and I did it
a jabber try